WITH US BECAUSE WE HAVE A FOX
NEWS ALERT.
NOW, AS WE MENTIONED JUST
MOMENTS AGO, BUSINESS WOMAN
TUDOR DIXON WAS DECLARED THE
WINNER IN MICHIGAN'S REPUBLICAN
GUBERNATORIAL PRIMARY AND THAT
MEANS SHE'S GOING TO TAKE ON
GOVERNOR GRETCHEN WHEN ITLESS
WHITMER THE QUEEN OF LOCKDOWNS
AND WE'RE PLEASED TO BE JOINED
BYITUDER IN HER FIRST POST
VICTORY INTERVIEW.
CONGRATULATIONS AND YOUR MESSAGE
TO GOVERNOR WHITMER WHO'S
WATCHING I'M SURE.
>> MY MESSAGE TO GOVERNOR
WHITMER IS FAMILIES WON TONIGHT,
FAMILIES CAME OUT AND VOTED AND
FAMILIES WANTS A FAMILY FRIENDLY
MICHIGAN AND WE'RE GOING TO HOLD
HER ACCOUNTABLE TO HECTORABLE
RECORD IN THE STATE OF MICHIGAN
WE WON'T LET THE PEOPLE FORGET
AND TRUST ME AS I'VE GONE AROUND
THE STATED, THEY HAVEN'T
FORGOTTEN.
>> Laura: NOW, SHE PUT OUT A
STATEMENT TONIGHT FOLLOWING YOUR
VICTORY, AND IN IT SHE SAID,
TUDOR DIXON HAS MADE CLEAR THAT
SHE WILL DRAG MICHIGAN BACKWARDS
IN REVERSING PROGRESS,
REBUILDING MICHIGAN'S
INFRASTRUCTURE AND SO DISTRUST
OUR DEMOCRACY, DANGEROUS FOR
MICHIGAN WOMEN AND FAMILIES,
BLAH BLAH BLAH.
SOUNDS LIKE IT WAS WRITTEN BY
ILHAN OMAR.
ITUDOR YOUR RESPONSE.
>> I'D ASK FAMILIES ARE YOU
BETTER OFF NOW THAN YOU WERE
FOUR YEARS AGO?
DOES SHE THINK THERE'S ANY WAY
TO DRAG MICHIGAN FURTHER DOWN
THAN SHE HAS?
DOES SHE REALLY THINK IT'S
POSSIBLE FOR US TO BE IN A WORST
POSITION?
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW WE'RE AT THE
BOTTOM, BOTTOM IN EDUCATION, WE
HAVE A PROBLEM WITH CITIES, WE
NEED TO COME BACK FOR SAFE
CITIES, WE NEED TO HAVE
BUSINESSES, A GOVERNMENT THAT
COMES AROUND THEM, THAT PROTECTS
THEM THAT WANTS THEM TO SUCCEED
AND THIS IS NO. WHAT THEY HAVE
SEEN FOR THE LAST FOUR YEARS BUT
THIS IS WHAT WE ARE GOING TO
DELIVER TO THE STATE OF
MICHIGAN.
SO MY MESSAGE TO GOVERNOR
WHITMER IS WATCH OUT YOUR RECORD
STANDS STRONG AND IT'S BAD AND
THE PEOPLE OF MICHIGAN WANT TO
GET RID OF IT.
THE ONLY PLACE WE'RE GOING IS UP
AND WE'RE GOING TO BRING
MICHIGAN BACK.
>> Laura: NOW,ITUDER YOU SPOKE
WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP A SHORT
WHILE AGO.
GIVE US A FEW LITTLE DETAILS ON
WHAT HE SAID.
>> HE'S PRETTY EXCITED ABOUT
THIS RACE.
HE SAID, LOOK, THIS HAS BECOME A
NATIONAL STORY.
YOU'RE GOING TO GET THIS WOMAN
OUT OF HERE.
YOU COULD GO UP AGAINST HER, I
ALWAYS KNEW THAT YOU WERE THE
ONE THAT COULD GO UP AGAINST
HER.
AND, YOU KNOW WHAT?
THERE'S SOMETHING PRETTY SPECIAL
ABOUT WALKING OFF STAGE WITH A
BUNCH OF PEOPLE THAT HAVE
SUPPORTED YOU AND CAME HERE JUST
TO SEE ME TONIGHT.
AND THEN WALKING BACK STAGE AND
TALKING TO PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
HAVING HIM SAY YOU'RE GOING TO
DO THIS.
THIS IS AN AMAZING NIGHT.
I'M GRATEFUL TO ALL THE PEOPLE
HERE IN MICHIGAN, I'M GRATEFUL
FOR YOU TO HAVE ME ON TONIGHT
JUST THAT I CAN TALK TO
EVERYBODY AND SAY ON NATIONAL
TELEVISION, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> Laura: TUDOR DIXON, THIS IS
GOING TO BE ONE OF THOSE GOB
NAHTORY RACES THAT THE NATION IS
WATCHING.
AND, BY THE WAY, THIS CAUSED
QUITE THE COMMOTION DURING YOUR
REMARKS JUST A FEW MOMENTS AGO.
>> BUSINESS WOMAN AND MOTHER FAR
LEFT AND CAREER POLITICIAN AND
NOW WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TRULY HOLD GOVERNOR WHITMER
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE PAIN SHE'S
INFLICTING ON EACH AND EVERY ONE
OF US DURING THE PAST FOUR
YEARS.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Laura: TUDOR HOW ARE YOU
DRIVING THAT MESSAGE HOME ACROSS
MICHIGAN?
WOMEN ARE BIRTHING PARENTS AND
MEN ARE BIRTHING PARENTS,
THERE'S NO MOTHERS ANYMORE IN
THE EYES OF THE LEFT.
AND WE KNOW WHITMER DOESN'T
REALLY BELIEVE IN WOMEN AND MEN
ANYMORE SHE BELIEVES IN CHANGING
ALL DEFINITIONS.
>> WELL, YEAH, SHE'S STUFRNLD ON
WHAT A WOMAN IS, SHE'S CALLED US
MENSTRUATING PEOPLE.
GROSS.
PLEASE NEVER CALL ME A
MENSTRUATING PERSON, WE'VE BEEN
CALLED BIRTHING PEOPLE.
MOMS ARE MAD.
THAT'S ONE JOB YOU CAN'T TAKE
AWAY FROM US, WHETHER WE ADOPTED
OUR CHILDREN OR BIRTHED OUR
CHILDREN, WE ARE MOTHERS.
MOTHERS ARE GOING TO STAND UP
FOR WHAT IS RIGHT.
THEY WANT THEIR NAME BACK, BUT
THEY ALSO WANT THEIR KIDS
TREATED RIGHT.
SO WE ARE GOING TO GO OUT THERE,
LIKE I SAID, WITH A FAMILY
FRIENDLY MESSAGE AND THAT'S
RESONATING AND IT'S GOING TO.
WE'RE GOING TO GO ACROSS THE
ENTIRE STATE OF MICHIGAN TALK TO
EVERYONE WE CAN.
WE'RE GOING TO COME ON YOUR
SHOW, WE'RE GOING TO BE OUT
THERE.
THIS IS A NATIONAL RACE NOW,
WHEN SHE RAN FOR VICE-PRESIDENT
IT BECAME A NATIONAL RACE SO
THANK YOU GRETCHEN, WE WILL MEET
YOU ON